hello guys okay we're going to continue
our blender
2.9 video editing how to and this time i
want to talk about transformations and
how to apply transformations on your
video this is zoom in zoom out rotate
and
basically all those so we're going to go
to file new
video editing and that will take us to
this video video editing that i have
described
if you still don't know what the heck
any of this is watch the first one i'll
leave a link down below or i'll leave a
link to the playlist of all of these
but that one covers all the settings but
yes you have to change this to ffmpeg
yes if you want sound
you gotta you gotta go down here to
audio and change it to aac
right so i'm just basically doing the
same thing i did last video of just
setting up where i want things to go
well you know so
some basic settings there now let's
bring a video in here and then
we are going to do some transformations
on it and i'll go over that
let's go to my d drive then go to
recordings there's a bunch of stuff here
i don't know just bring something in
i'll hit the home button to get a full
extension hit the page up button to go
to the end to copy and paste this end
and there we go this light blue one is
the video this other one is
the audio so if i click my video
and then you hit shift a i get this
uh this menu you can also click i think
add yeah
effect strip transform we're gonna look
at transforms
so adding a transform is easy you click
on the video
and you hit shift a and you go to effect
strip
transform i'm going to control z that
real quick optionally you can click on
the video
go to add effect strip transform those
are the two main ways of doing it so i'm
going to cover this in as fine as detail
as i can you if you split up your
your uh video say i do a cut here and i
want to transform i don't know maybe
just a small section here
so i'll cut again there i can click this
little clip and add a transform
to just it and once again
shift a shift a is what brings us up so
let's do a transform on just this
section now what this transform allows
you to do
over here in your effect strip where it
says
uh has some settings you now have a
scale you now have a position and you
now have a rotation
that's the really the only ones we're
going to be talking about in our case
so we're going to click uniform scale
otherwise it does some stretchy effect
so if we click to like the middle of
this
we can see that if we scale the x it's
going to stretch it out if we scale it
in it's going to
zoom better squash it down and similarly
with the y
but if we click uniform it keeps them
the same and usually that's what you
want so i'm clicking uniform
it does a zoom in or does it zoom out so
when you render a transform section
it does that literally and if you're not
seeing this stuff over here
make sure that you've clicked the
transform you do have to highlight the
transform
and make sure over here you're on strip
because if you're on any of these other
ones it's not going to do it
you're not going to get these options so
just hopefully that
makes it clear for some people that
might get
stuck because they jam random buttons or
whatever they do i don't know
all right so if we want to just zoom
this in
we can increase the scale so maybe it's
not zoomed in on the right
place maybe you want to zoom in
somewhere else that's where you adjust
these positions the x and y here
if you move it to one side or the other
it goes different
head to different places so maybe i want
to zoom in on this weird little guy
over here so i put it right here
so now that those are set when it goes
to this section of the video
it is going to zoom in on that transform
so that's how you
have just a standard zoom in and then
once it leaves it it's back to normal
and that's basically it but also you can
rotate so on this transform you can
apply
this rotation which does spins as you
would expect
and you can just type in literally what
you want default positions are zero
default scale is one so you can just
type those in if you want to reset
and default rotation is zero so you can
do that on any part of your video you
can chop up little sections
add transforms to them and
and get your desired result so maybe
something is really small like maybe i
want to go over here and i want to show
off a piece of code or something that's
hard to see in the video
so maybe i just want to zoom it in maybe
it's a little too far
and i'm going to do another little quick
trick here i'm going to grab both these
edges where it's darker
click here shift click here and press g
and i can slide
where this edge is so maybe i want to
transform on this here
effect transform and uniform scale
zoom it on in bring the x over this way
a little bit
another thing that often comes up once
you start layering and transforming is
well i'll show you well i'll just get a
couple small sections here
cut this here zoom that way out i don't
know there's some old video
delete that and i'm just going to grab
another one here
and and i'm just going to grab a small
chunk of that
cut there delete the other part
delete that and i got this little chunk
of video here
so maybe you want to like layer videos
on top of each other but you want one to
be in a different
like one up in the corner or something
so that you can be talking about
something
and have a little clip of it up in the
corner and
you can do that with transforms but
there's something you have to be aware
of so for example if i take this clip
which is on top
and i go effect strip transform zoom it
out so that it's smaller
and there we have it it is smaller but
now the clip behind it is not shown
so when this happens when the clip
behind is not shown it's because this
transform when you click on this
transform
it defaults to replace
everything so in this adjust section
under the strip
it says replace and you can change this
to overdrop and then it just
overdrops and that way you can have it
still show what is behind it too so
that's just another tip something you're
going to run into
is you're going to have this default
which is replace
uh so it doesn't show
the stuff behind it and if you want to
you just gotta change this to overdrop
and that will take care of it now i can
be whatever talking about it and then
show a little clip or whatever
and it looks like you know the cool
things they do on the news where they
have a tv up in the corner and they're
like ah you know
showing screenshots or whatever so
that's how
that is done with these transforms if
you got a full
video clip it's about the same for
bringing in images and changing the size
of images too you can apply these
transforms to
images that you drop in as well and do
the same stuff
i want to go just one deeper for the end
of this just to give you a little more
advanced knowledge if you wanted to zoom
in and zoom out
and not just do a quick jump here's what
you can do you can keyframe these in
and the hotkey for that is i or you can
press this tiny little dot over here if
you click it
it saves a keyframe now all this does is
it saves at that part
wherever your playhead is it saves at
that point wherever you are so if i go
to the beginning of this transform
well let's say say this is my final one
i want it to be at
whatever in 2.23 and at these positions
so i'll click here and i'll just save
all these and click all these dots i
could optionally
hover over these and press i it does the
same thing so now when it gets to this
location it's going to save that
keyframe however it needs multiple key
frames to work with
to interpolate between them because
right now it's well it's got a keyframe
it needs another one so that it can
change values
so if we go somewhere else on the
transform like at the beginning
and set it to its defaults which are 0
0 and then scale 1
it's back to its normal and we'll save
those by clicking here
click click click and now as it goes
from this to where that other keyframe
was
it will now interpolate and do a zoom in
type effect so i'll click forward slowly
here
there you go so it does a zoom in effect
and then once it gets to that one
it just stays if we want to stay for a
while we can go near the end
save those keyframes again that way it
locks it in for that
short time then go to the end of it and
have it do a zoom out back to normal by
setting all these
back to their defaults
scale 1 save those
and now what will happen during this is
it'll zoom in
stay for a moment until it gets to the
other keyframe stamp
and it hits this other keyframe stamp
and i'm pressing the right arrow to
advance one frame at a time
and you can tell because these are
yellow that it's at the keyframe and it
can't
keyframe stamp and then the next stamp
zooms it out
so it's going to start zooming out so as
this video plays back
and once you rendered it rendered it it
will just do a zoom and zoom out
like it looks like that
so there you go that's the basics of
adding transforms
and keyframing it in to make it do cool
stuff i do this all the time in my
videos to kind of show stuff you've
probably seen it in some of my videos
this is one of the most common effects i
use
and let me know if you have any
questions or if anything is unclear
thanks for watching hope this helps you
with your video editing on blender and
getting your transforms right
i'll see in the next one and i'll
probably cover some other thing just one
effect per video is probably good peace
out guys
[Music]
you